we've got some breaking news on the
political front and the former culture
secretary Nadine Doris has announced
she's standing down as an MP at the next
general election of course a very loud
uh and prominent supporter of former
prime minister Boris Johnson and has not
been much of a supporter on the current
prime minister Rishi sunak uh did
Annette made that announcement earlier
today on her television program she said
those MPS who drank the Kool-Aid and got
rid of Boris Johnson are already asking
themselves the question who next she
goes on to highlight the fact that of
course Boris Johnson won that big
majority a point that she highlighted
many times and saying the public would
not let us get away with it I'm afraid
that behavior is what I have to remove
myself from she says that despite having
loved the job for every year that she's
done it I'm now off whether a full-time
career in Media awaits or not we shall
see but the former culture secretary
excuse me Nadine dory's and former
vociferous supporter of Boris Johnson
has decided she will not stand as a
conservative again at the next uh
election